[Musique]
un jour peut-être historique mercredi
dernier se tenait au château de hambach
en allemagne la toute première réunion
du comité franco allemand de coopération
transfrontalière
autour de la table des représentants des
deux états des élus des collectivités
parlementaire si la journée a été
consacrée à l'installation du comité 12
sujets ont pu être évoqués par les
participants
si un sujet frontaliers est aujourd'hui
une difficulté ceux qui peuvent le
résoudre sont tous dans la pièce
d'aujourd'hui dont personne ne peut nous
dire ah non c'est quelqu'un d'autre
c'est ailleurs c'est pas moi c'est lui
c'est là ce qui fait que deux parfois
depuis dix ou quinze ans il ya des
difficultés que les frontaliers
connaissent très bien sur la mobilité
les déplacements le détachement des
travailleurs les manifestations
sportives et je pourrais faire une
longue liste on les a tous abordés ici
et maintenant chacun responsable celui
qui a la possibilité d'agir est devenu
responsable de l'action et donc on a
remis les choses à dire au bon niveau
il ya beaucoup de coopération transfert
qui marche et aussi des choses qui ne
trouve pas de solution et c'est ici
qu'on va le faire le comité trouve sa
source dans le traité texte la chapelle
signée par la france et l'allemagne
l'année dernière à l'origine de la
proposition le député du bas-rhin
sylvain va zermane réunir autour d'une
même table
autant d'acteurs étatiques et régionaux
est une grande première on s'est aperçu
que depuis des dizaines d'années il ya
énormément d'obstacles ce qu'on appelle
les irritants du quotidien qui ne trouve
pas de solution et qui ne trouvent pas
de solution parce que c'est compliqué de
coordonner tous ces gens là de les
mettre autour de la table pour se mettre
d'accord sur la meilleure solution
faut-il changer une loi faut-il modifier
un texte faut-il développer un projet en
tout cas vous avez autour de la table
tous ceux qui prennent l'engagement que
tous les ans on puisse faire le bilan
des problématiques concrètes qu'ils ont
réussi à résoudre
au fil du rhin on trouve de nombreux
organismes de coopération
transfrontalière traitant le sujet
précis comme par exemple la navigation
ou gérant la coopération sur les
territoires délimités
ainsi sur les sept districts existant en
france 4 se trouve en alsace témoignage
de l'importance des enjeux
transfrontaliers de notre région au sein
du comité aucun elle assurait cette
conférence ne sera pas une couche de
plus dans le mille feuilles de la
coopération transfrontalière ça n'est
pas juste une structure transfrontalière
de plus mais c'est une structure qui va
être agile qui doit être efficace pour
intervenir rapidement dans le quotidien
des citoyens
et pourquoi pourrons-nous être agile et
efficace parce que nous regroupons à la
fois des acteurs locaux donc des élus
locaux mais également des représentants
de l'assemblée parlementaire franco
allemande
et puis également des représentants des
gouvernements français et allemand ce
qui nous permet de faire avancer très
rapidement les projets d'ailleurs j'ai
demandé cet après-midi même que tous les
six mois
à chaque réunion de notre comité de
coopération eh bien nous faisions un
point d'étape de tous les projets pour
voir le bout pour voir leur avancement
objectif du comité traiter les questions
du quotidien à grande échelle
en témoignent les sujets abordés ce 22
janvier rencontres sportives mobilité
travailleurs détachés la santé ou encore
les voyages scolaires qui ce dernier
sujet peut paraître trivial
ils cachent pourtant des enjeux
importants comment coopérer si on ne
maîtrise pas la langue du voisin
aujourd'hui on voit qu'il ya beaucoup
d'obstacles au mobilité scolaire
or si on veut développer la connaissance
d'une langue allemande
je crois beaucoup à l'immersion de sorte
que les enfants soient dans une
situation des changes en allemand toute
la journée
je pense que c'est aussi par cette
méthode là que nous pourrons renforcer
l'apprentissage des langues donc ça
c'est un exemple très concret je suis
très heureux de pouvoir le rapporteur de
ceux de ce travail là que sur lequel on
va échanger avec tous les acteurs
autre sujet évoqué le dossier épineux de
la fermeture de fessenheim ont joint la
centrale nucléaire cessera de produire
du courant pour le territoire c'est une
perte importante en termes d'emploi
ainsi au conseil départemental on
souhaite s'appuyer sur la coopération
avec nos voisins allemands pour
redynamiser l'économie du secteur
c'est le comédien de coopération
transfrontalière en lui-même n'a pas de
pouvoir décisionnaire au conseil
départemental
on espère qu'il facilitera les travaux
engagés d'autres travaillant déjà au
quotidien avec nos voisins allemands sur
l'après centrale nucléaire de fessenheim
ce que j'attends d'eux veut c'est qu'ils
fassent partie de la société d'économie
mixte franco allemand que nous allons
créer très prochainement pour nous aider
à attirer des entreprises dans le
secteur de fessenheim et je peux vous
dire qu'ils sont très très dynamique
dans ce domaine avant noël nous avions à
berlin un workshop organisé par le land
du bade wurtemberg et le bund allemand
pour essayer d'intéresser des
universitaires mais aussi des
entreprises à ce territoire de
fessenheim est oui
chaque jour 46 mille français
frontaliers vont travailler en allemagne
un chiffre en baisse ces dernières
années bien que notre voisin les besoins
de main d'oeuvre
si la connaissance de la langue est
indispensable pour décrocher un emploi
encore faut-il que les frontaliers
puissent se rendre outre pour créer de
l'emploi il est nécessaire d'avoir de la
mobilité la mobilité ça par exemple la
liaison ferroviaire colmar frei drogue
qui avance qui avancent même bien
puisque d'ici quelques semaines nous
allons signer la convention de
financement pour les études approfondies
de cette ligne dont il est toujours
prévue l'inauguration en 2026 donc vous
voyez du concret qui touche les gens les
alsaciens dans leur quotidien si
mercredi dernier les deux départements
alsaciens siéger au comité de
coopération transfrontalière 11 mois
c'est la collectivité européenne
d'alsace qu'il y aura son siège
c'est très important pour nous puisque
le coeur du projet c'est l'europe
collectivités européennes d'alsace l'une
des des compétences majeures de cette
nouvelle collectivité va être la
coopération transfrontalière
nous en sommes très fiers parce que
l'alsace va être en quelque sorte le
coeur européens de la france et je peux
vous assurer que ce sera le coeur
battant de la france moi j'ai une
rencontre du comité dans six mois
autour de la table tous se donne un an
pour tester la pertinence et
l'efficacité de ce nouveau cadre de
coopération transfrontalière
[Applaudissements]